my name is Henrik and today I want to
talk to you about server-side rendering
and why we broke the web first I'll
introduce you to the problem with
client-side rendering only and after
that I'll show you a solution and how I
solve the problem using next share which
is a framework that really solve
server-side rendering and client-side
rendering really well so what's wrong
with client rendered Web Apps in the
first way when a user comes on on to my
app the app responds with an empty HTML
page after then after that they'll
download like 10 gigabytes of my awesome
JSF 10 to 20 seconds later the user sees
the first thing on my page this is like
the pattern we use when we're building
client only web and this has in my
opinion many problems that are still not
really solved most people say okay you
don't need server-side rendering because
Google is able to index our page on the
client side they use something like
phantom shares and can in index our page
so search engine optimization is not any
more topic but there are other user
groups on the internet that depend on
your server serving HTML and not some
cryptic JavaScript code one example is
for example Open Graph many services who
want to provide Rich Snippets to your
page what's app guide Facebook and they
need Open Graph text and only some of
them are able to index these Open Graph
text or the title of your page on the
client side
so saying Google saw solves the problem
server-side rendering is not really true
but we in our community decided to say
okay server-side rendering is a bit
complex so Google says we can index out
your page so we drop this part
many of us are ignoring this and I did
many years so my solution to that is
next year next year is the minimalistic
JavaScript framework that solves in the
first place place server-side rendering
and by using a universal approach and
react so if we use next year what what
do we get out of the box the first thing
of course is server-side rendering but
only code listed but also code splitting
is a big issue in that part like how do
we split our code on the different
routes or sub pages of our app so the
client doesn't have to download the
entire fjf on the first request the
second has a third thing it solves our
client-side page transitions if we have
multiple routes in our app and we do a
normal page transition to another route
we are losing state for example in redux
when you navigate to another route the
entire page gets loaded again and our
redux tour will be empty so we need to
reinitialize it if we have client-side
page transitions this is not an issue
anymore I think the first big client
side page transition was something like
towable links in Rio in Ruby but I'm not
really sure and this is a bit different
and we get out of the box a build system
we don't have to read tons of web pack
Doc's and guard dogs and needs two weeks
to
get started with our project we can get
started immediately
but if we want to extend this build
system we still can add our own web pack
loader so it's really extendable and it
works pretty well the build system is
based on web pack - so we get free
shaking out of the box which solves the
problems of two big bundles in addition
to that they come with their own CSS
solution which is similar to style
components but um works a bit better
with server-side rendering but you can
still disable the solution and use your
own favorite CSS solution so guys let's
do some live coding and girls and
oh here we are so we want to start from
scratch because I want to show to you
that how fast you can get started using
this kind of approach so we starting by
yarn initialize you can use NPM of
course and so now we have the package
Jason created and now we need to install
our dependencies at first we install the
next beta version next has evolved in
the past month and they have are close
to the 2.0 version which we already use
in production but it's still in beta so
things may change then we need react
next could have bundled react with they
are packaged but the cool thing having
react as a peer dependency is you can
use react if you want or something
similar to react and and last but not
least we use I install just for our demo
isomorphic such a ponytail would
probably a better way but for simplicity
reasons I use this so and now everything
that's downloaded hopefully the internet
will do everything cool we are done we
have installed everything we need let's
start coding so
we have a package.json file next year in
order to get started really quick we
don't need an entry fire oh my god just
say that you can't see anything so here
we go and so we can drop the main entry
point next year we'll add this for us
but later we can do it on our own way so
we are still flexible on this let's add
two tasks to get started I think it's
always a good convention to like add
some script so first we add a desktop
careful this getting really complicated
done so and this allows us to start a
death task which will do life reloading
code splitting and we'll compile our app
in a really performant way so if we have
a really big app we won't have to wait
like two minutes until the bundle is
filled next let's add production tasks
we combine the build tasks and the
starting of the server and one task this
is just for this demo
Wow complicated so now next year f has
one important convention they introduced
a new component if you're familiar with
react you already probably know
functional components higher-order
components dumb components and next yes
it's just one more component it's called
top level component the top level
component is the component in our app
that gets initialized at the top level
so if we call a route this component is
the first component in the hora
we call these component pages okay
so let's create an index page here you
can see it
Oh
so we are important react and for
simplicity reasons we use like a
functional component this component
returns our knives hello world let's
start the dev server we are calling our
stripped tasks from the package Jason
you could call next if you have it
installed globally please ignore the
depo creation warning it's a web pack to
issue there's nothing to do with next
next listens on port 3000 for default
that you can change it if you want so
awesome we got our first page nothing
special you think
but this page actually rendered on the
server the initial request was rendered
on the service we disable JavaScript we
get the same result
nothing special react Doom can be
rendered on the server so why is this
guy telling us so let's create a second
route let's call it cookie actually what
I want to build is like a little app
that and shows you some cookie messages
from from these fortune cookies if you
know them so we create a new route
called cookie
all right
let's check if it worked that is if we
navigate between these two pages and
we're losing states
nothing is special about that but next
year has helped us here the first cool
thing about it they have their own
router probably you'll think why don't
they use react router for this that is
awesome but when you do server-side
rendering react router for doesn't solve
all your issues
next is build so it doesn't need to know
all routes in advance and in react
router you need to tell the app or
inform the every route of all the other
rows and that's pretty difficult so
that's important link component from
next and link to another page
since the link component the hrs will be
populated by the link component we put
the href to the to the link component
let's do the same on the oh this didn't
work sorry so since we are on the cookie
route it doesn't make sense to reference
the cookie route here but the landing
page on the landing page we just do the
same for now
[Music]
of course we need to link component
these two files are kind of isolated and
this is since we have these entry files
like in the good old PHP days and you
isolate each route from each other if
you work in a big development team and
your friend is putting minesweeper on
his routes for example and which may
have a lot of code
he won't influence your part of the
application which is pretty much meeting
so let's look what we just built wow we
have a link if I disable JavaScript on
this page the page will be still
completely functional will fall back on
websites like in the 90s so this is a
great way of progressive enhancement the
user even if he has no JavaScript or a
big latency he can use your JavaScript
app immediately so javascript is not a
real important dependency just for like
small javascript things like account or
so they won't work us you need something
like state management but links and
showing the initial content will always
work so if we open the counter and we
click this link we get a client-side
page transition one second I need to
reference the right atria click the
cookie the build system just received
that the request that a cookie route and
it's not built yet
so he's doing it really fast so he just
builded the cookie route if we go back
the entire thing gets even quicker then
and we don't have the full page
transition but we could call this route
directly and we get just the code we
need for this route
this approach comes with another nifty
feature we can use prefetching out of
the box just add the prefetch param to
the link component and you are done so
when we now load this hello world
example we first get an initial response
with HTML then the JavaScript is
evaluated and may put extra
functionality to our HTML page and after
that we prefetch the next page so it's
already loaded when the user has read
like the caption of our page the the
next page is already there so if I click
cookie now it's there immediately which
is pretty nice we're not losing state we
just improve performance of our website
we use code splitting we use common
chunk so common parts of the application
will be bundled into a common chunk file
so we don't have to reload this on every
route right now I just showed you
something similar to a static page
generator we haven't populated any of
these components with props and that's
what we're the reason what's really
interesting about it so let's add that
real quick ok I'm cheating a bit
Oh
instead of returning a functional
component we can return a normal reactor
so right now we on the cookie route
so you probably all know this pattern we
create a react class for the random
method and actually nothing has changed
okay we try to get some props but right
now the app doesn't have any props so
let's add them next yet at one static
method nothing more just one method it's
called get initial props in this static
method we have access to the request
object if this component was rendered on
the server we have access to the
response object and if we are declined
these objects are new finds so let's
check out if we on the server
easy as that in the beginning I told you
we need isomorphic fetch fetch I hope
you're familiar with it it's like the
new HTML request so the new way of using
Hayek's requests this API is not part of
note but we can like polyfill or pony
fill this API and so we can call fetch
and our some external restful RP and
from the client or from the server so
this is the universal part of our app
after we got the response will return
adjacent we're using a weight here so
adding functions if you're not familiar
with them and don't want to use them you
can just simply return a promise from
this function or just an object if you
don't do any I think stuff and after we
fetch the JSON we use destructuring here
to simplify a few things so please
ignore these they are not next specific
and we return the initial props let's
real quick look at home at this cookie
RP this is the response we get
we only interested in the fortune part
object so we use destructuring to
extract it and we feed our top level
component and with a fortune object so
we have access to the ID or the message
let's check if we get a cookie I love
life coding fun you don't need this
right now
here we are I just loaded this route
directly in order to show you the
advantages I want to compile our new
next up in production mode so you won't
see all the build systems specific stuff
this is not interesting to show the
point
so stop the desk server start the
production task or script and start yes
so this is now compiling our entire
application and starting the note server
to serve this
as you can see we try to reference the
route that didn't exist sorry for that
we could use we could disable JavaScript
now and the app will still work as
expected if we navigate to the landing
page we get a client-side page
transition or a 2 1 X 1 minute and we
want to go back this is where they act
the error comes from just like to recap
we're showing like the props message
there so we get the props from the
static method get initial props
okay just saw a spelling mistake please
excuse me for that so now we are calling
the cookie route what now will happen is
we get the next route via I ox
so the top level component from the
cookie route will be executed on
declined and not on the server this is
just because of the client-side
transition this was really fast because
we prefetch this route so let's recap in
the network inspector inspector first we
call the localhost route or the landing
page and after nine milliseconds the
user could always already use our page
he was able to immediate read some stuff
then he has to wait another four
milliseconds until the JavaScript
functionality initially got loaded maybe
five milliseconds until he could use our
route like all the kind specific stuff
after that the prefetching kicked in we
got the cookie page with an IX request
which took us another six milliseconds
and from that now on we are done but the
cookie page needed to call an external
RP you see some here will go up some
Hague web so that was called on the
client now we got the cookie
informations and that's it so if we do
this again with a direct request so we
don't transition to that route with a
with a client request we get at the page
immediately and this is like really
awesome if you believe it or not so
let's stop live coding for now and let's
recap what we just did
so I'm just a recap we have like these
three basic components and next share as
introduced like this new top level
component which is similar to add any
other react component just add the get
initial props static method so we just
created a react up in a few minutes we
solve the complex problem of server-side
rendering we added prefetching we added
client-side page transitions on end code
splitting which works on a big scale as
well next year as comes with a lot of
other features that you don't need to
use but you can use them and it's really
convenient to use those first of all as
I already mentioned the web pack to
build system which is extendable it
comes with a server route handler so if
you and you just saw it looked similar
to static site generator but if you want
to use express to do your routing at all
you want to use core so you can use
similar literally every server-side
node.js framework so you're not bound to
any of these next year as has a lot of
community examples and which all you
which will point you in the right way so
in the next repository just take a look
at the examples what parts are supported
so one interesting example is the
server-side caching example we can
actually cache our server rendered web
apps if we have a big web app we can get
there in addition and extra performance
and extra performance boost by caching a
server-side rendered response in some
kind
of cash like Reddit and get speed like
an aesthetic app in addition to that
it's support state management libraries
the community contributed for example
examples for react form of X or and you
can use whatever styling library you and
would like to so you don't you're not
bound to and they are styling solution
for example with solid Ron post CSS
shallow yeah and many more so I hope you
got some insights into next shares
please take a look when you're at home
and I promise you it's really awesome
because you get really fast and
developing and quite impressive web apps
so thanks a lot for your attention
[Applause]
if you have any questions I'll be here
around you can ask now if we still have
time and all will see each other on the
conference thanks
[Applause]